so I'm curious how are you day-to-day
handling this pandemic is quarantine are
you going crazy no not even close I mean
obviously it's worth mentioning that
this is it's a very weird time with so
much worry if you let yourself really
worry about your loved ones in the state
of the world in the future then it's
very very overwhelming but as far as
like my little slice of quarantine it's
really fine I enjoy my husband I get a
kick out of him we don't have kids so we
don't have to like educate them this is
a great time to not have kids again
who's laughing now
exactly it's really not it's not
terrible I kind of also feel like I've
been kind of like training for this my
whole life
yeah yeah I'm not really quite lazy yes
it's but normally like when this isn't a
global pandemic if I have a lazy day I
work hard and then I'm very lazy when
I'm not working and I find that when I
have like a normal lazy no pandemic day
it's coupled with this like horrific
inner monologue that I need to be doing
more and accomplishing more losers gonna
be different and now I haven't even
lazier day and this is gone radical
self-acceptance anything goes now
this is gonna sound a creepy question
but what are you wearing that's what I
like to I'm not doing that I know I text
you sometimes and say what are you
wearing that's a different whole thing
often it's whatever yeah not to be
discussed not to be discussed on air but
what are you like are you someone that
gets dressed up I have found I'd make an
attempt every now and then to put on
like to dress like I've got to go out in
the world but then I don't go out in the
world I try that but then I fall right
back
- elastic waistbands yeah t-shirts
really yes yes I wear I feel like I'm in
like a sci-fi space movie it's my
favorite part of the day because I take
off my sweat suit I take a shower and
then I put on a clean sweat suit and
that's like the beginning of every go
and do their rounds yeah and then they
realize the computer is smarter than
they are and is taking away their oxygen
or everything goes wrong they're just
putting on their sweat suits and walk
around the spaceship are you learning
anything like I'm learning things about
my neighbors because I'm usually gone
during the day but now I'm learning you
know I can hear people talking I
I sometimes witness things are you
experiencing that at all yes definitely
my I definitely think that I've become
you know how every neighborhood has like
a creepy woman that just stares out the
window all day yeah good yeah oh yeah my
favorite my favorite show currently is
looking out the window across the street
and there's this I haven't actually seen
the neighbor her name is Celia I know
this because there's another young woman
that comes by about once a week to
scream at Celia and it goes on I mean
for like 45 minutes she's really serious
Celia come out of the house yeah I mean
like the vocal work is impressive she's
great it's so loud and then she'll like
say her piece and storm off and then
she'll come back because she remembered
another thing I don't know what it's
about I know it began because the girl
was pissed about something Celia did to
her mother because the episode one was
like it goes on I love it and weird
because I'm genuinely like I don't like
to see people fight I don't I don't
violence but it's gotten to a point
where all I want is for Celia to come
out of the house and for them to fight
each other industry you're invested in
this drama you've put in the time and
now we need to get to like the big act
to moment where we finally Celia now I
have a theory
I am theory because this is where my
mind goes the woman on the street
murdered Celia a while ago hear me out
okay cover up for it she goes and the
body's up there to cover up for it she
goes every day knowing that you're
watching to say Celia come out why don't
you come out
that's her alibi you are her alibi and I
would testify that Celia is definitely
in there up and I were you educated me
on the facts I would have absolutely
stood in front of a judge and said
there's no chance see that's not it
yeah yeah I'm telling you or she is in
there but she's in the wall right this
is a murder case you should call the
police immediately before the woman on
the street sees this and then comes
after you that's where the movie goes
next I think that's a great idea I'm
gonna start calling the police every
hour
[Laughter]